lo umilia rowe è un vecchiaccio non ha
speranze fai cagare vallelunga centro
guida sicura adiacente al prestigioso
podium è una struttura all'avanguardia
capace di riprodurre qualsiasi
situazione di emergenza nella vita
quotidiana grazie all'aiuto di resina
bassa aderenza piastre per lo
slittamento forzato muri d'acqua due
squadre dieci concorrenti si sfideranno
a colpi di freno quella grande sfida
della sicurezza che sarà il più sicuro
zio gianfranco 18 anni portati malissimo
suo figlio saverio 22 anni lo so
qualcosa non torna gabriele già tg2
stuntman formidabili fratelli dinamici
atletici in una parola prorompenti
guglielmo ed enrico altri due fratelli
due stuntman formidabili dinamici al 13
in una parola una bugia
lavinia amante di registi tanto forte
quanto piccola di altezza ovviamente si
narra che la sua prima patente gli e
l'abbia consegnata giulio cesari giulia
la pasticcera di famiglia cucina per
tutti tranne che per la famiglia
gianmarco corvo della malora ladro di
sorrisi abbiamo subito personaggio che
mi ha già messo un malore
il metro e novanta di giudizio pur bravo
paolo bravo paolo bravo bravo siamo
pronti per presentarvi le due squadre
che si affronteranno c'è stata una
selezione fortissima ed è con onore che
vede presenti marco giulia saverio
gialli uniti sono la squadra denti
enrico vallarino sia gianfranco gabriele
la squadra dei cattivi sappiate che vi
faremo che rende scritti per come non
così hai notato come sono tristi buona
la sbandata una slide con ri fine a
bassa aderenza e in riga artificialmente
che ti fa fare la sbandata esercizio che
facciamo è la perdita d'aderenza
dell'asse posteriore e non capisco
questa cosa che i buoni sono tutti
brutti e cattivi ne sono bellissime non
l'ho capito che tu vuoi cominciare con
un salto dello schizzo
ma certo
controllati e confutare la teoria che le
donne al volante non sono un pericolo
costante
non certo ma ci proviamo
sono la prima persona di tutto quanto
noi sapremo larini a fare la primissima
prova perché noi siamo i più audaci qua
a dire un po o privato sta arrivando sta
arrivando che ragazzo sperando in un
testa coda di cui lei può mica dei non
pochi dice e anzi subito è vero noi
siamo i buoni testa coda non mortale
sezione
[Applauso]
[Musica]
l'avana vi mette la senti giulia a roma
buona fortuna ce l'ha fatta cadono tutti
missione brave tutte governate mia è
stata un po più bloccata con il braccio
[Applauso]
l'ostacolo acqueo colonne di acqua
terribilmente non pericolosa che mettono
a dura prova i riflessi per evitare
l'ostacolo acqueo dovrete frenare
proprio col pallone per terra forte e
qualora la situazione lo richieda
provare ad evitare l'ostacolo
la sfida generazionale c'è il giovane
contro il vecchio riflessi zero allora
lui è giovane avrà i riflessi diciamo
quelli pronti ma e rimbambito perché non
ha esperienza lo umilia rho buona
fortuna a zio non è vero
[Musica]
lo ha dimostrato quello che volevo dire
io che è un vecchiaccio non ha speranze
ma che deve fare imbarazzati capito e mi
viene d'istinto capito lasciare il freno
e poi continuare diciamo destra anti
stintino mai detto ha sbagliato
totalmente il nostro compagno
[Musica]
questo proprio io l'ho passato se vince
mio padre perché nel frattempo
innanzitutto vorrei subito una querela
perché mandato di quello che prende in
giro
comunque voglio dire l'esperienza ha
pagato e quindi gianfranco è sicuramente
più bravi li faccio in realtà stato più
bravo
la rotonda aria di esercizio con resine
a bassa aderenza per la gestione del
sottosterzo del sovrasterzo nella
rotonda cui parliamo che la perdita
d'aderenza anteriore
al suo fianco consob aula
buttiamole giu io sono pronto vado
ragazzi è stato bello già morto
baican è indifendibile
forse abbiamo perso il punto esercizio
che altamente complicato dobbiamo
guidare il treno con la manovra degli
anni fa
la vecchia cara nazione
mi sento meglio
[Musica]
ma fermano i ragazzi non è un bagno e lo
puoi dire quando hanno fatto cambiare
tutte e due però capisco che devo dire
che paolo è stato veramente bravo
la grande curva percorso colpi di vino
sul resina bassa aderenza irrigata
artificialmente per mostrarti tutte le
grazie che fai quando percorrere l'area
quello sarà il nostro punto di frenata
ci sarà l'inserimento di curva un
birillo centrale sarà il nostro punto di
corda ricominciamo a riaprire il volante
[Musica]
ecco questo punto siamo tutti a bocca
aperta ma non si può perché facciamo gli
occhi non è andato giù ai mezzi di
trasporto chiede lontani anni luce
stessi una macchina una bicicletta
ognuno pattin elettrico qualsiasi mezzo
draghi di un po questo pronti fa
questa la fagiolata anzi ci metto il
mondo mentre parla di insegnamento e
mezzo di trasporto ideale
e nascosto di applaudito in realtà un
cesso c'è troppa pressione addosso
adesso qui è il mandato fortissimo
ragazzi sarà dura ma chi mi aspetti da
quelli partiamo vena prima pedina frena
ho trovato io sono un popolo
ahi ahi ahi si no
bravissimo molto più bravo di giungere
madonna basterà siamo
bravi tutti noi è andato più sicuro ha
esitato può rinnegare era esitato molto
di più
ma veniamo al buco e devo eleggere
guglielmo
[Applauso]
è un punto gli hanno pure regalato loro
cari auguri possiamo vedere gli stuntman
che fanno tutti e quattro i circuiti per
vedere come se la cavano la sbandata
l'ostacolo la rotonda l'altra
gianluigi contro gabrigo euro
[Musica]
un freno al cavallo
guarda lontano guardo si penserà faccio
alcun questi cattivi
ogni scuola e john faccia voglio
spingere treno così pazzo stato
sfondando il penale ho preso il volo per
atene ha sporcato di autrice di cotanto
diceva idoneo ma l'attrice del freestyle
[Musica]
intanto scritte in data così penso io
perché poi si fanno a gara vediamo che
seif ha promesso di roma
gabriele tanto diceva tanto faceva un
cane l'ho visto proprio lì che girava il
professore della casa di carta
[Musica]
ma
credo
meno male che non era la mia sfida
infierisce su di lui senza pietà non
compete a casa ringraziamo la ci guida
sicura per averci permesso di passare
questa giornata ci siamo divertiti ma
abbiamo anche imparato un sacco di cose
serie
un'altra queste legata all'istinto
spesso lo seguiamo davanti a un problema
e non sempre ci consiglia la cosa giusta
da fare a volte dovremo imparare come
comportarci specialmente quando si
tratta di problemi alla guida io mi
lascio qua sotto un link in descrizione
qualora vogliate approfondire quelli che
sono i corsi di guida sicura a
vallelunga che altro dire se vogliono
istinto mi sono fatto suo taglio di
capelli tornando indietro non so se ho
fatto la cosa giusta comunque metteteci
un light per favore perché oltre che al
divertimento ci abbiamo messo il cuore
nella creazione di questo kolossal di
giuro iscrivetevi al canale noi ci
vediamo giovedì alle 14 con un nuovo
video e fateci sapere nei commenti se
secondo voi meritavano di vincere i
buoni oi cattivi e chi secondo voi è
stato il più bravo
[Musica]